3.3
of the entire monetizable portion of an
audio visual work is now being used to
claim 100
of the money of that audio visual work
you're totally willing to like pay them
their their percentage but they're
taking all of it what do we do
there's a lot of stuff dude
for now mount a new turtle more turtles
oh my god we're gonna go so slow with
these turtles another turtle soft boxes
for all these turtles i don't think
we're ever gonna need any more led
panels ever a house of cards made out of
turtles
have some turtles hustle turtles
aperture sent us a few lights because we
needed more lights to film everyone a
light on top of the camera is not enough
we normally film people
roughly here
there
uh now we have lights at each desk to
bring the vlogs a little bit higher
production value not over here they're
not gonna lie to you don't worry not yet
playing the lights
on that blue thing oh yeah i got three
lights up i got three lights put
somewhere
so what if i put a light right here and
just use it as a tungsten it's not about
the work it's about filming the work
yeah and when you can't film the work
the work is useless apparently according
to carmichael it is it is
i'm like sitting here trying to do work
on something he comes barging he's like
what are you doing it's not on camera
you're wasting our time i'm like oh my
god you're so right
pause
two years ago we made the darth santa
video our friend casey edwards made a
beautiful composition that took the best
parts of star wars songs mixed with some
of the best christmas songs mixed with a
little bit of magic of his own just last
friday we received a copyright claim
from music publishing company which now
claims monetization on the entire video
we had used a portion of the imperial
march which means that all of the
monetization now is going to them here's
the problem with that
monetization of an audio visual work is
a little bit more complicated than it
might appear on its surface a video hey
guys we made a video we're gonna put it
on youtube and monetize it here are all
the copyrights that are now involved
under visual you have things like the
photography that you actually took with
your camera characters in the videos
trademarks other copyrights and any
other visual assets that's half the
entire value of a video let's go to the
other half audio under audio of course
you have sound design foley voice assets
adr other copyrights and music when most
people think of music they think of
songs well songs are actually broken
down into two different types of writes
in the us sound recordings which is the
actual recording of the song that you're
hearing and the musical composition
which is the underlying composition of
the song the words and the melody now
this is where our problem begins music
publishing company that owns the rights
to the imperial march the musical
composition have filed a claim on our
video no they're not claiming anything
visual they're not claiming anything
under sound design they're not claiming
anything on any of the other songs
they're not even claiming our sound
recording of it no they're just claiming
under the musical composition i've gone
into a deep analysis here and i've found
that there is only four seconds to seven
seconds and the marker from 158 to 216
is the entire portion in which we use
the musical composition of the imperial
march that's 21 seconds 21 seconds out
of a total of 159 seconds for the entire
video that's 13.2 percent of the entire
video we need to divide that by two
because it's just the audio portion and
not any of the visual portions so in
total we have used six point six percent
but guess what there's more divide this
number again by two because it's only
the musical composition and not the
sound recording this number's wrong it's
only 3.3 percent of the entire
monetizable portion of an audio visual
work is now being used to claim 100
of the money of that audio visual work
at that point
what happens
we've never gone that far down the
rabbit hole before we're gonna file a
dispute on this to see what happens
if i come really close to the lens
there's the blue light hitting me and if
the camera is white balanced to these
orange lights in post this blue light is
going to look purple but if we turn it
off now we got really moody and dark
lighting we have to boost the camera and
whatever so we'll put light up so bounce
off the ceiling let me just drill into
the support beam of the building
that's what it's for right yeah support
i don't even know if we have the right
screws for this they found some coins
yes coin droppings dude
dude
it was stuck to my lips like the 2000
year old tendrils just like grabbed on
into my lip and didn't let go here's the
thing about elon musk he's our savior
yes but i would pretty much never want
to work for him
he's afraid that elon musk would take
all the
the camera time away from ren that's the
exact reason actually
god i can't believe that stuck to my
what's up christian what's up people
christian what are you guys doing
i'm uh modifying the workspace
before jake gets here to tell me not to
do it
sounds like a plan
so here's the problem that i was talking
about with the way that youtube breaks
it down into a very simple issue these
are the only things that you can select
to say the copyright claim is not valid
whereas the truth behind this matter is
that the copyright claim is valid it's
just that they're not entitled to 100
monetization they're only entitled to
3.3 of the monetization i'm happy to
give them that 3.3 percent but i can't
do that with the way that the youtube
back end is set up so i have to choose
something what do i choose i own the cd
or dvd first of all why is that even an
option because people don't even own cds
and dvds
so what do i do which one do i pick
cable management's the thing to do
cable management so i took the orange
cable i nailed it to the top
and i even nailed the end of the bundle
up here so it's easy to just grab and
plug and then this guy is nailed once
onto this wall to stay out of the way
and i took this multi plug rolled them
up
put it behind the leg and nailed the the
head here just loose enough that we can
extend it if we need to
so normally if someone's working at the
bench this is what they look like but
now
you got to turn off those tungstens
and then the you can control the color
if you want from there but if it's too
bright damn it and it just kind of
bounces off the ceiling there it does
and then it's also hitting me directly
too so a little bit more of a straight
on top light
big difference
what do we do
i'm gonna pick that this video is my
original content and i own all of the
rights to it because that will at least
allow for the conversation to be
determined as to who does in fact own
what i'm going to continue with it
because i think it's the best choice out
of a bad batch of choices they even warn
you take a second to consider everything
that you put in the video it doesn't
matter if you recorded it free from
television purchase dvd purchase a video
game or recorded it yourself learn more
about copyright on youtube before you
click the box below this to actually
move forward with a claim
no
that's what i went to law school for i'm
about to make a claim here what i expect
is that this will prompt a conversation
with the actual music publisher it's
impossible to say with 100 certainty
that we own all of the rights because i
know we don't this is the only way to do
it out of the seven options because none
of the other options were applicable at
all
would you or would you not agree
[Music]
what are we watching snake regurgitates
live snakes